[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on the 29th of June I'm
John Connolly The Spectators news editor
and your host for this week
coming up on the show
Putin faced one of the largest tests of
his authority over the weekend as Wagner
leader yevgeni pagosian drove his troops
towards Moscow as the Reckoning begins
how worried should we be and what could
Russia look like after Putin I'm joined
by Owen Matthews and Dimitri alparovich
what is the Unspeakable truth about the
housing crisis in Britain Lana Shriver
writes for a column this week that it's
legal migration but is she right Lionel
makes her case on the show
doping has been an age-old problem in
the world of Athletics and several
high-profile athletes have been exposed
for taking performance enhancing drugs
could there be a world in which athletes
compete in a space where doping is legal
and encouraged Aaron de Souza and Damian
rally join me to discuss
and finally you may have seen a sudden
surge in people wearing blood glucose
monitors news today suggest they can be
a way to monitor health and lose weight
but Isabel Hardman thinks these fats
could do more harm than good she joins
me on the show
before we get going thanks to our
sponsors Canada wealth management for
supporting the show can a cord or
experience wealth planners and
investment managers or for unwavering
support in its challenging times visit
candywealth.com for more information and
if you enjoy spectator TV then do
subscribe to our YouTube channel just
click the Subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the Bell icon so
you never miss an episode
first up can we begin to imagine a
post-putin world in the magazine this
week we've taken a look at the Fallout
from yevgeny pagosian storming on Moscow
and the mafioso style relationship
between him and Putin joining me now is
consultant and specialist Dimitri
alparovich and spectator writer Owen
Matthews
Owen and Dimitri thank you for joining
us on spectator TV
um now Dimitri to start us off it's it's
been a few days now since uh pagosian
called off his coup on his march on
Moscow he since resurfaced in Belarus
um what's the situation like in Russia
at the moment has the has a threat to
Putin and Moscow in particular been been
completely neutralized
well the immediate threat has abated and
one of the things that Putin is now
looks like to be considering at least is
whether to execute a broader Crackdown
obviously pagosian has now been exiled
at least for the moment to Belarus and
by the way Belarus is hardly an exile
because Belarus has extradition treaties
with Russia Putin yesterday implied that
maybe there might be some criminal
charges that would be pursued against
pagosian for things unrelated to the
Mutiny right the amnesty was given for
the immunity itself but he can strongly
be prosecuted for corruption Miser
creation of State funds tax evasion
which by the way uh doesn't even need to
be made up because pregosian is very
likely guilty of all of those things so
as Henry Kissinger once said it has the
added benefit of being the truth but and
Belarus can extradite him at any moment
so
um that that can be dealt with but
broader than that certainly has a
problem in that the Russian military did
not side with progression but certainly
stood aside and let him roll into rostov
let him get to the almost the outskirts
of Moscow without being stopped and the
people that either had prior knowledge
of this uh Mutiny or that let it happen
could be dealt with and uh put there's
no doubt and oh and I probably Owen and
I are probably in agreement on this
there's no doubt that Putin has been
wounded by this but I don't think he's
been wounded mortally and uh if he
executes a major Crackdown Allah erdogan
to go after any of uh potential
opponents or people that were not
sufficiently loyal he can reinforce his
strongman image yet and the Wagner
troops themselves who kind of took over
rustov you know were marching further
northward what's happened to them now if
they've been absorbed into the Russian
state or
not yet so there's this Lumen deadline
of July 1st
um uh stemming from the order that
shoigu had given on June 10th which
really precipitated all of this that
said that all private military
contractors with Wagner being of course
the most prominent have to be dissolved
and people either have to sign contracts
with Mod or just go home but essentially
cease to exist Putin has reaffirmed that
yesterday that this indeed should be the
case or they can go I guess the third
option now is to Belarus but right now
they're uh presumably in their camps
still in luhans can occupied Ukraine
they're still very well armed so there's
still a question of who is exactly going
to disarm them but the Russian
government does have one leverage and
Putin revealed this of course we already
knew it that all the money to pay for
these people to feed them is coming from
the Russian mod so if they stop paying
them and also at the same time present
an option that if you can want to
continue to be paid here's a contract to
sign with M or D they're likely to get
many of them to sign on and that's one
way that they can disarm them and
reabsorb them into the military and I
mean this brings us nicely on to your
piece in the magazine this week which is
sort of quite remarkable it's about the
fact that Wagner whilst the most
well-known and not the only private Army
in Russia uh I mean can you tell us a
bit about these groups and what kind of
uh what kind of danger they post they
pose to Putin I guess
well it turns out that indeed a Wagner
is the most prominent and most notorious
but uh there are several different kinds
of uh private military groupings uh one
of them which is sort of a
um separate story is uh ramzan kadurov's
um uh
uh essentially praetorian guard which is
notionally part of the Russian national
guard but is paid for by the Kremlin but
I'm as basically under the personal
command of ramzan khadir and then
there's a whole swathe of corporate
armies uh that have been put together by
gaspram some of them have been existed
for several years and they had their
origins in private security companies
that did secure the the that protected
oil and solution installations for
instance in Syria uh but there's I count
at least a dozens of corporate
Affiliated uh private military groups
which reflect essentially the Russian
government has been subcontracting
military recruitment because uh as we
saw on September 21st last year I was
actually in Moscow at the time when it
happened uh mobilization caused Panic it
caused a massive outflow of of of men of
a military age and it caused a rash of
protests including in Pakistan and so on
so clearly the Kremlin has been
desperate for men right from the
beginning of this or you know from when
the military campaign started going
wrong and uh so desperate are they that
they're just willing to uh pay private
companies to assemble these private
armies
um private military companies notionally
they are they're not literally the
private Army of the board of gas prom uh
let's be clear they do actually have
some kind of subordination within the
structure of the Russian military and
they're paid for by the Russian military
um but nonetheless I mean that's a
clearly a potentially extremely
dangerous situation as um as the Wagner
Mutiny showed and there's a third type
of
um uh private military formation and
that those are essentially sort of uh
bodies of volunteers
of military age they've been put
together by uh the siliguration of the
the the head of uh of uh Crimea and
another some others associated with uh
various Cossack bodies with uh in South
Russia with Constantine malafiev who is
a Orthodox uh nationalist TV Mogul and
billionaire so you have a lot of
military formations Beyond Wagner whose
loyalties are you know emotionally
they've signed up all of them for
contracts with the Russian army as
Dimitri we just mentioned but that
doesn't necessarily mean that their
primary loyalty in the case of the set
that the center does not hold their
loyalties May well be divided and do you
think that attempt by Putin to Reign
them in is is going to be successful
well there's anyone that needs raining
in
um and it was precisely Putin's attempt
to reign in Wagner but essentially to
shut it down that was the approximate uh
cause of this uh of this Rebellion as as
Dimitri said I mean that they had to
essentially Rebel or die uh Putin
ordered the disbanding essentially of
Wagner and then at least by pregosian's
own account they then came under
shelfire rocket fire uh from their
inside because uh the Russian defense
Ministry wanted them dead so that was
really the reason for this Mutiny they
did not have a political agenda
pregosium was actually quite careful not
to criticize Putin personally although
he viciously criticized Sergey Shogun
the minister of defense and he viciously
criticized the way that Kremlin has um
has fought the War so it was definitely
more of a mutiny than a coup so in that
sense it's different from 1917 when life
cavneilov who was a very popular General
marched on on petrograd and basically
destroyed the credibility of the
provisional government
is not that but clearly
um the spell has been broken
um that uh Putin is the guarantor of
Russians Safety and Security I mean he
clearly is not and furthermore I mean
the reaction of the people of rastavon
Don
uh they treated the wagner-like heroes
they came out on the streets and then
their hundreds shouting Wagner Wagner
and when the police showed up to
supervise Wagner's withdrawal uh they
shouted Shame Shame so it though those
scenes are definitely echoing I think in
Putin's head assuming of course that
he's seen them we don't know what he
sees he doesn't use the internet he
thinks it's a CAA plot but um you know
clearly this is a very profound blow
tools Authority and thirdly and finally
you know the Wagner takeover of rostov
Van Don this is the headquarters of the
Southern military command which is the
nerve center of the Ukrainian War was
unopposed
and despite the fact that Putin spent
the day handing out medals to the people
who supposedly saved Russia from Civil
War that doesn't really make it true no
one saved Russia from the Civil War
except maybe Alexander lukashenko who
finally who essentially communicated
Putin's complete capitulation to the
rebels
and Dimitri so say if you are Putin hold
up in the Kremlin at the moment
obviously this has been a massive blow
to your Authority as you're both saying
where does he see the next threat to be
because you know he must be incredibly
paranoid at this point
he probably is paranoid but honestly I
don't think that there is any eminent
coup and it is worth repeating what
everyone just said the pregosian did not
want to replace Putin and no nor did I
think he could have replaced Putin I
mean imagine the scenario where he's
wildly successful he rolls into Moscow
he takes the Kremlin he you know arrests
or shoots Putin and then what
you know you can't run the country with
your 25 000 people mercenary group when
you have no political base when no one
in the country is particularly loyal to
you across the elites across the various
Governors and security for forces and so
forth so congratulations you may have
just started Civil War or disbandment of
the country where everyone's gonna
pursue their own interests but you're
not really running it just because
you've taken one building right in
Moscow so that is a problem that anyone
would face that would try to challenge
or replace Putin you know a certain
General perhaps could do what pagosian
has done but they don't have the
political power they don't have the
national recognition they don't have the
elite support to be the chosen candidate
if you will and that's uh the one Saving
Grace for Putin is that he has
eliminated you know effectively all
opposition over the last 20 years to his
Rule and and made himself
um sort of Tina as the stock market has
been saying for three years on other
things there is no alternative right
um but the danger to him is not
necessary that I think he's going to get
a bullet in the head from someone
surrounding him but that increasingly
the elites will decide that if pregosian
can get away with this what can I get
away with can I start doing things in my
own little region if I'm a governor of a
you know distant region in Russia where
I'm not going to ask Kremlin for
permission to perhaps steal more to
aggregate more power I'm not going to go
mother may I I'm just gonna go do it and
ignore what the Kremlin is doing and in
some ways if Putin continues to allow
this to happen he may turn into his own
worst nightmare which is his predecessor
Yeltsin who towards the end of his Reign
had become a joke and and was mostly
ignored by everyone he was still
president and could still issue orders
but everyone was joking around him uh
with um uh for power and building their
own Clans and and trying to dismantle
pieces of Russia for their own benefit
and that's what this can get into if
Putin does not put a stop to this and I
want to emphasize that he still has an
opportunity to consolidate power after
this major blow he can do a Crackdown
erdogan style reinforce it he's still
the strong man if you do this to me I'm
gonna make you pay and and convince
everyone that maybe it's not worthwhile
to continue to ignore him and I mean
that's that's been Putin's Point hasn't
in his speeches since the since the
uprising that he is the so the only
thing standing between K you know Russia
and Chaos as it was at the end of the
Communist era I mean do you do you think
as well that that's that's where we're
heading though sort of a fraying at the
edges of the Russian State and the
weakness of his authority there
yeah well stability has always been
Putin's unique selling point right from
the beginning
um the you know right from 1999 he came
to power as a sort of Macho uh prime
minister here former head of the FSB and
there was a series of as yet unexplained
highly suspicious apartment bombings and
he in Putin was this sort of tough guy
who was able to promise to
um you know rub them out in the in the
Outhouse and so on um uh the the the the
main threat I think to Putin or the main
end game for Putin is that the elite
uh the Russian Elites decide that he can
no longer guarantee their Privileges and
can no longer actually be a credible uh
sort of guarantor of not just we're not
talking about Democratic politics we're
talking about the of the contract
essentially between the Kremlin and the
business Elite and the bureaucratic
Elite it's already been put under
enormous strain by the way by the war
which has been undoubtedly unbelievably
bad for business in a huge sway so the
Russian Elite have had a major uh damage
to their assets to their
um uh to their freedom of movement their
their their their businesses they have
you know the war has hurt them in the
wallet but you know as we as we can
observe there's been actually very
little public criticism for within the
Russian Elite uh they just prefer to
stick with Putin as they have done for
20 years and remain silent but we keep
people don't discuss enough the fact
that Putin is up for re-election in
eight and a half months time
March 17 2024 is the next presidential
election everyone kind of assumed that
the the the that he would just uh uh you
know stand again and that would be
rubber stamp through
but I think there's actually a lot of uh
uh um you know quite strong feeling
within the elite
um that you know maybe he's not the
right guy but there's a flip side to
that
uh and that is that perhaps unintended
effect everyone has been predicting
everyone is saying and it's and it's
true and Dimitri and I agree we really
agree but on this one we do strongly
agree that he's been weakened that he's
been weakened by this that's undoubtedly
true but there is a sense in which uh I
think the pregosian Revolt has shown
that there are forces beyond the
kremlin's control that Ultra
nationalists they're very pro-war this
was not an anti-war Revolt the people
that came out on the streets of rostov
were not anti-war they thought Wagner
Were Heroes because they were the guys
that had been giving the ukrainians the
best kicking you know these this is not
like the sort of Revolt of pacifists at
all and the fact that uh the security
and stability of the Putin security
state has proved to be so brittle so
fragile actually uh makes it rather
daunting and frightening to mount a
challenge to Putin so in that sense
actually I think for people within the
Russian Elite who might have been
thinking of you know shuffling off Putin
I think this whole precaution episode
May give those people considerable pause
uh because I think they realize very
clearly and has been demonstrated over
the weekend that actually uh sort of
catastrophic loss of authority by the
Kremlin can very quickly descend and
that's kind of the point about my uh my
piece about these private armies you
know the conditions are there uh
potentially uh they're not there now but
the conditions are potentially there for
something really catastrophic to go
wrong and for the Putin's succession to
go out of the hands of the elite who
would manage it into something
unpredictable and and catastrophic which
would be and chaotic which would be
terribly dangerous not just for Russia
and the world but also for Ukraine by
the way
and Dimitri just to finish off we
probably should turn to Ukraine I mean
from their perspective you can imagine
it's only good news that Russia is in a
bit more chaos than it than it was
before but do you think this is gonna
it's Uprising he's gonna make a serious
difference to the war effort or do you
think Russia have managed to get a
handle on things now
no and as we saw even in the midst of
the chaos over the weekend uh guess what
the strikes on Ukraine continued they
launched a huge barrage of missiles
literally as this Mutiny was taking
place uh one of the first things that
pagosian did when you took over the
Southern military District headquarters
which is the Nerf Center for running the
war in Ukraine uh is he said that
everyone's continuing their jobs I'm
making sure that the war is prosecuted
the supplies are flowing the missions
are being conducted he did not put a
stop to any of that and of course the
line still held you know as the
ukrainians keep probing yet in zaporizia
and elsewhere the Russians were not you
know surrendering or fleeing they're
holding strong and and fighting and by
the way history also
um uh is a useful lesson here uh Owen
mentioned 1917 1917 was the year of two
revolutions right the revolution against
Cesar that brought in the professional
government and then the Bolshevik
Revolution that overthrew the
provisional government in the mid list
of all of that you know massive civil
unrest in the country the War uh and
Russia participation World War one
continued um up until the Bolsheviks
ultimately made peace with the Germans
so the idea that Wars just stand because
there's unrest in the country is not
supported by historical evidence and and
as Owen mentioned the people that were
revolting here the Wagner mercenaries
and pagosian were not anti-war at all um
they think it should be prosecuted with
even more aggressiveness and with total
mobilization of society and the like so
I don't think that it has an immediate
impact on the war but but here's where
the war plays a role for Putin if he
suffers another major defeat in this war
let's say that uh the Ukrainian counter
offenses succeeds they are able to
liberate much of the South threaten
Crimea that's another blow to the regime
right he's already demonstrated weakness
this is now going to have an additive
effect and that can really I think uh be
very dangerous for him and as Owen said
like the elites can decide that maybe
it's time for him to set us a step aside
not necessarily in a coup but you know
uncorrectly mentioned that next year the
presidential election can be pivotal so
you could see uh people including
friends of Putin coming to him and
saying look old man you clearly don't
want this job anymore it took you 13
hours to respond to this Mutiny once it
got started why don't you step aside it
could be someone like Nikolai Patricia
for example an old buddy of his from the
KGB days who's the uh head of the
National Security Council actually older
than Putin but he may say my son who
you've helped promote now an agriculture
Minister the Next Generation let's pick
him as a next candidate you stand down
from the elections he he runs and wins
and we'll make sure that you're
protected you keep your ill-gotten gains
uh no one is going to send you to the
Hague and uh we're going to move on to
to to New Blood you could see that
scenario playing out you know impossible
to say How likely but that's one way in
which power can transition away from
Putin without there necessarily being a
coup
an interesting Twist on the Manning gray
suits there um thank you Dimitri thank
you and that was fascinating
what are the causes of the housing
crisis and is there one cause that
people don't want to talk about author
and spectator columnist Lionel Shriver
joins me now
Lionel thank you for joining us on
spectator TV
um you start your column this week by
talking about the housing crisis and in
particular when you appeared on any
questions last year and you said
something quite shocking to the audience
um that caused a bit of a stir can you
can you tell us what that is
well uh someone in the audience asked of
how how I suggested that we improve the
chances of young people being able to
get on the housing ladder
and I said uh women immigration
just go what did she say
um
but the truth is that
uh for 50 years
britons have had a below replacement
rate fertility and I was astonished to
find that figure
uh which means that the only source of
um
of the growth of the population is
basically
newcomers
um and and I I one of the one of the
problems that the UK has is that it's
never
um grappled with what's the what's the
long-term game plan on population you
know how many people do you want to live
on the that I want and
um
and it's it's it's a it's it's primitive
it's it's along with you know where is
your water coming from or your what is
your long-term energy plan what is the
long-term demographic plan because uh
no population can infinitely grow and
that's just
a physical fact so how many people does
Britain want to have and all all we've
got is short-termism so and if you're
constantly
um trying to solve the
uh the problem of age structure by
bringing in more people the logic of
that is an infinite growth in population
and the column this week is mostly
looking at the issue of Housing and
that's one of the real limits on the
number of people that you can bring in
um
ever since I've lived in Britain
governments have talked about increasing
house building they never meet the
targets
and that's real it's this pressure on
population that is driving the uh
unaffordability of British housing I
mean you know it's again it's a simple
uh economic rule of supply and demand
and when you can't meet Supply then the
the price goes up always and
um so you've got this situation where
especially in London some sad little
Hubble is a million pounds right
um and the same problem uh pertains to
rent because we uh when housing is
restricted then the rent goes up
um and then the government makes it
worse with all kinds of policies I could
do another column on the rental
situation
um Lana just keeping to supply at the
moment I mean you've got some quite
remarkable statistics in your piece can
you just give any of you a sort of a bit
of context about how much the population
of the UK has gone up
uh because of immigration compared to
sort of previous years
well if you look at
um if you look at the British population
from
1973 for the next 25 years you know
before Tony Blair
it was very close to steady state I mean
it it increased by about two and a half
million people
um and with you you still got the baby
boom people having
children that makes sense that there
would be a small increase
of immigration was
almost negligible
um but then in the next 25 years
uh Britain increased nine and a half
million
and it it's the difference is huge and
it's clearly coming from immigration and
this is also uh the the increases
accelerated by the fact that immigrants
especially non-eu immigrants tend to
have larger families
um and and migration watch has done a uh
meticulous study on the implications of
this rate of immigration and you know on
on the housing market and
last year according to the government's
own figures
uh we had a net gain in Immigration of
000 people
and so migration watch was looking at
okay if we just stay at that rate not
increase which is what we've been doing
every year more people come in
um
if we just stay at that 606 000 per year
how many houses do we have to build
and there is a range depending on
certain assumptions especially depending
on the fertility rate but uh it's
consistently many more houses uh than
are currently being built and have any
chance of being built and then you've
got the the the other problem which I
mentioned is that
not only do we have planning permission
roadblocks but
the money is in luxury housing that's
that's what the developers want to build
I mean if you look around London I mean
even in my kind of crap neighborhood
um
luxury housing is going up everywhere
and
it happens to be hideous
they're all using the same architect
yeah
on talented I have to I can picture them
all now now you're saying that well you
know this does not help
the majority of people who who need to
get on on the housing ladder or need a
place to rent
um it's it's playing to the the top of
the market and
and it's and that's not where the need
is
I'm not even saying you don't think
we're building enough now wholesale I
think the government have said they've
got a target of 300 000 homes a year do
you think that would be enough or do you
think that's gonna drop in the ocean
kind of thing
even 300 000 a year at current levels of
immigration is insufficient
um
you have to build over 300 000 a year
and by the way you have to add on uh
some housing that has to be built just
to stay where you are uh as a homeowner
I will testify
that buildings Fall Apart
day
um
so while migration watch didn't specify
what that level is I don't know but it's
it's not zero so
um
what I'm suggesting is that you know
building building housing is is hard
it's cumbersome it takes up space there
are many many issues to consider with
the you know the roads and the energy
and and and the water
Etc it is easier for us to control the
demand than the supply I was going to
say because there are some people who
make the argument that you know
immigration is quite important to the UK
economy and that we should just kind of
build build build to kind of meet that
demand rather than focus on reducing
um you know the supply of immigrants I
mean what do you make of that argument
well I think any demographer would tell
you that if you are ever going to have a
steady state population
um you have to go through a period of
economic pain
which means that you you have too few
young people supporting too many old
people and then eventually that evens
out you know you're going to have a
bulge in the population otherwise you
just keep bringing in more people
um migration watch did another study
which I touched on in another column
um which looked at uh this one was back
in 2010 and so they were how how many
people you would need to bring in to
maintain the same support ratio as there
was in
um 2008 and
uh it had something like three they
calculated something like 300 million
people which is you know closer to the
population in the United States
um by
you know I don't want to misquote them
something like mid-century or the end it
doesn't even matter or the end of this
Century uh because Britain would never
be able to
fit 300 million people under the island
and that's just by way of an
illustration that you cannot keep
solving the labor shortage or the the
the the need for
um
more young people to support the old
people you can't keep solving that by
bringing in new people and because
because
the new people get old like everyone
else and then they become the old people
that you need to bring in more young
people to support
and uh you know
ideally uh the the
fertility fertility rate goes up a
little bit and that would be the optimal
way to even out the support ratio but
that's not something that
is easily legislated so
maybe we shouldn't hold our breaths yes
um I should say as well you make this
clear in your piece but for anyone
watching um you make a quite clear
distinction between illegal
um illegal migration on boats and what
you're talking about here which is more
legal migration do you think the UK
debate probably focuses too much on the
boats and that kind of leads us to what
odd policy decisions
oh yes I mean I can understand why the
small boat situation gets so much
attention it's um it's very dramatic you
know it it makes good TV all these
people getting off the dinghies and
bunged onto these tiny boats it's filmic
but
um that's not where the numbers are
uh the the problem is legal immigration
uh the home office is letting in huge
numbers of people and
um and the figures you know the figures
also don't include things like Visa over
stairs the people who come through the
airport and and say they're here on
tourist visas and then just disappear
we have no idea how many of those people
are
and that's so much easier than getting
into a dinghy
I bet there there are far more Visa over
stairs than there are
um migrants in small boats
that's not to say we shouldn't solve the
small boats problem which is getting
worse and is
starting to be statistically significant
um
but it is something of a distraction if
we're interested in keeping the numbers
under control and and therefore getting
on top of things like the housing
shortage uh we should look to Legal
immigration primarily
brilliant thank you very much Lionel
my pleasure
next should athletes ever be allowed to
dope in athletics does some of the most
notorious Sportsmen of our time have
come under Fire for doping some think it
is time to open the floodgates Aaron de
Souza founder of the enhanced games has
done just that Damien Riley thinks this
could be the end of sports as we know it
they both join me now
okay Aaron and Damian thank you for
joining us on spectator TV now before we
start um we're going to watch a little
bit of trailer about the enhanced games
which you've launched this week Aaron
I am the fastest man in the world
but you've never heard of me
I have broken Usain Bolt's 100 meter
record but
can't show you my face
[Music]
proud and hand
the Olympics hate me
I need your help to come out
I need your help to stop hate I need
your help for the world to embrace
science
brilliant um it's quite an intriguing
trailer that can you tell us a bit about
the enhanced games what it is and why
why you think this is needed the
enhanced games is an alternative to the
corrupted dysfunctional Olympic Games
and it's the first international sports
event without drug testing we're openly
embracing scientific innovation in this
era of rapidly changing social norms so
when is this going ahead next year is
that right plan is to run the first
event in December of 2024. and sorry the
athlete in that trailer there says he
can run faster the 100 meters than Usain
Bolt that is at his world record Is that
real absolutely yes and who is this
person yeah well what I say is that
um being enhanced is a journey and it's
a journey of coming out it's a it's a
quite a tough one for athletes to even
discuss this uh and I admire all the
athletes who have been involved in this
project particularly those who have
agreed to publicly be attached to the
project people like Olympians like Brett
Brett Fraser crusading Smith Roland
Schumann and they're the ones who are
the most courageous and so Damian you
writes about the enhanced games have
perspective life this week reminders
saying you don't agree with it but you
also think that doping is a massive
problem in sports at the moment so can
you explain a bit Yeah so I suppose I'm
cynical about the status quo I think
this is filling an actual vacuum I think
that uh I think a lot of people believe
that athletes in general are doped to
the gills and competing and the tests
don't work and they're not being caught
and so they have no choice but to cheat
and I think this is probably
fitting a vacuum saying well if cheating
is happening on an industrial scale
anyway why not make it legal so I think
that's what you're doing that's
absolutely right and I'm not saying
eliminate the Olympics uh oh control you
know we hope that there is a natural
world of the Olympics the all slow
Olympics and on the other side a science
enhanced world of the fast exciting
enhanced games I mean do you worry Aaron
that you know a lot of these athletes if
they take lots of performance sensing
drugs a lot of these drugs have pretty
nasty side effects I mean do you worry
that you're creating sort of a dangerous
situation for the people taking apart
ultimately adults with free and informed
consent must be absolutely must be
entitled to make decisions about their
own body my body my choice your body
your choice and I don't think any
government or paternalistic Sports
organization should be telling adults
what they can and cannot do with their
own bodies the risks that one wishes to
take is ultimately an individual Choice
should we have told the Apollo
Astronauts they couldn't have gone to
the Moon because it was dangerous maybe
those people who went in the submarine
down to the Titanic was that too
dangerous maybe having 10 cups of coffee
or maybe even eating sugar right where
do we draw the line and I do not trust
the government or it's entities in in
the Sports World to make that judgment
for individuals and David you make a
kind of different point which is that
the value of these games is kind of less
because we're not sort of seeing the
limits of the human body yeah can you
tell us a bit about that yes I agree I
don't disagree with anything you've just
said I think that if people want to
ingest these substances I mean I'm
guessing the people that went down in
the submarine maybe they could have been
more not to do that it was quite
dangerous but I yeah I don't think I
disagree with that in principle what I'm
saying is that uh I think adult games
which is what this is you call it the
enhanced games but it's the dope games
um essentially is quite dull it becomes
a bit like bodybuilding where you know
that everyone's on steroids and you can
see what they're doing and it's kind of
interesting spectacle for a little bit
but I don't think it will have the
relatability of say the Olympics where
um there's universality to it which is
that everyone can run and jump
um without taking you know anomaly do
you think that Hollywood is unrelated
relatable because most uh Hollywood uh
celebrities use plastic surgery to
enhance themselves most male movie stars
are probably on steroids you know I'm
not going to make any accusations but
you only need to look at all the
superhero
physiques and they're largely
unattainable by mere mortals and so does
that make Hollywood unrelatable or does
that make something that we aspire to I
think that's an interesting question I
think Hollywood has become increasingly
unrelatable in recent decades I think
maybe before uh all the film stars were
enhanced through plastic surgery and the
story lines were ludicrous I think it
was more relatable
um so yeah I get your point
um I ca I yeah I'm not I'm not
disagreeing in principle with it I just
don't think it's particularly
interesting or because it doesn't tell
us ultimately much about ourselves it
doesn't tell us uh I believe that the
purpose of sport is to tell us of what
we're capable as a species and what the
human body is capable of
um but if you know that people are
enhanced by definition uh they're not
like us well I think you actually have
to distinguish what you've said there
you've said
um the purpose of sport is to show us
what we're capable of as a species and
then you said purpose of sport is to
show us what we're capable of as
individual humans both both right and as
a species uh scientific progress is
probably our greatest asset and so we
are at the enhanced games so visibly
illustrating the capabilities of
athletic Excellence individual athletic
Excellence plus Collective scientific
progress but doesn't the word enhanced
in the title imply
on human inhuman better than human
absolutely and shouldn't we aspire to be
better than what we are today something
greater
um you know the use of enhancements is
commonplace in many Industries I gave
the example of Hollywood
another example might be the city of
London the Wall Street the financial
sector the use of neural enhancements
such as adderall are so commonplace when
there was a shortage a few months ago it
caused a drop in overall productivity in
the United States by three percent and
the use of beta blockers the use of beta
blockers by classical musicians
orchestral musicians might be up to 75
percent helps them Focus right and so I
think as a society we should celebrate
the use of technology to make us better
does something like a writer who uses
chat gbt never
I should say that here at The Spectator
is there anywhere you'd draw the line
Aaron I mean you know people putting
biological implants in do you think are
there any drugs that you think no this
is too far
um you know we have such an opportunity
with all the scientific and
technological change that is happening
and so the existing sports federations
are stuck in the past
the Olympics are focused on this ideal
of Greek gods and ancient history and
we're focused on the future and the
ethical complications that will come
with social and technological change are
gigantic so think about
um crispr babies Gattaca babies there
are children being born today who whose
parents have had them genetically edited
so that they are enhanced babies and in
10 or 15 years time they will want to
compete at the Olympic Games this is
eugenics you're getting into well no I'm
we're not getting into this at all it's
parents who are making this decision for
children today with crispr babies should
they be banned from sporting competition
no I think more interesting question is
what about
um say Oscar Pistorius with the blades
yeah his feet and he could run faster
than human beings yeah would you welcome
that would you say that that a man with
springs on his feet you can compete in
100 meters or 200 meters or the high
jump uh hydrogen is it just drugs or is
it enhancement in other ways so in terms
of physical like cybernetic enhancements
maybe not at the 2024 enhanced games
we'll have to design a rule set so that
can be a fair and level competition but
absolutely and I would love to see an
athlete a paralympian compete side by
side and be fully abled athletes
wouldn't that say something
extraordinary about the capability of
people with a physical disability to
rise up and to you know compete on the
same level my point is that it wouldn't
I think it would be ultimately dull to
see that I think it is yeah I get it and
I can see it's a sort of dystopian
vision of the future
maybe this this clip will be used in
years to come of some idiot saying it
was going to be boring when it's the
most watched thing ever but I think
ultimately 3.1 million views on Twitter
in one week alone it's an interesting
idea and it's a sort of Pop conversation
people have had when you just legalize
the drugs yeah but it takes it separates
sport from from us because we aren't
enhanced kids running in Parks aren't
enhanced when I go for a jog I'm not
enhanced uh
these people are no longer relatable so
if I if I if I run in a park if I run my
terribly slow 10K and I can look and see
who the fastest humans ever to run 10K
on that's interesting to me because I'm
a human they're a human none of us are
enhanced but if there's a bunch of
people as I say in the article they may
as well be on wheels for like uh it is
totally they are using anabolic steroids
and I'm not therefore big wow I mean
Aaron are you tempted to sort of just
cut out the humans entirely and just
have machines race up and down on the
track
well F1 is a wildly popular sport f1's a
very good example so F1 as I said in the
article the engineers are far more
important than the drivers and so your
games I think the scientists would be
far more important than the athletes so
the story would be about what the
scientists did I'd actually disagree
with that because the highest paid
people in Formula One are the drivers
right the drivers earn more money but if
you're a driver in a terrible car it
doesn't matter but if you're a terrible
driver in a great car have you ever
tried to drive a
Formula One car it's extremely difficult
I haven't yeah
Lewis Hamilton in a car towards the back
of the grid he's not winning F1 races
and they're all it's a good it's kind of
a good analogy because the drivers are
all
to you know Elite drivers there isn't
that much to separate them but the
performance of the car does separate
them and therefore it's about the
engineers the drivers may get the more
money but it's a really interesting
point I mean what do you think will
separate number one and number two in
your enhance games race will it be the
skill of the athlete or the skill of the
program they're on in terms of drugs it
will be a combination of both right and
that's uh exactly like the case in
Formula One there's skill and tactics of
the athlete uh plus the engineering
capabilities of a whole team of what is
beautiful about formula one is that you
can so obviously see what the team is
right you know it's the engineers it's
the mechanics coming in for a pit stop
it makes for exciting television and
formula one is having an absolute
Renaissance uh it's television numbers
are skyrocketing and it's engagement in
the United States is off the charts and
um I think this is where the future is
going because it shows us the
potentiality of us as an entire species
and there's always this kind of tacit
lie among at the Olympic Games about
individual Excellence you don't see the
coaches the trainers the
physiotherapists the doctors behind
those athletes and let's be open and
honest it takes a village so you have to
scientist and the athlete on the podium
together holding the syringe I think uh
so I think I I totally understand what
you're doing and I think it's great and
I think there's a natural vacuum I
interviewed uh the chemist memo
Hernandez who doped he was a doping
chemist and he doped all the Marion
Jones and he says all the finalists that
the the Beijing 100 meters Olympics and
he was very straight he said if you if
you're a low-level athlete you and you
give me 10 000 quid I will make you a
potion that probably will show up on on
tests so you take your chances it might
not show up on others if you give me a
hundred thousand pounds I'll make you
something so good no testing the work
and detect it and this goes on and it's
been going on for ages we see athletes
smashing times that were set by dopas
across a range of disciplines so the
reason that people are watching less and
less Athletics and others well not main
Athletics is because we don't believe
what we're seeing anymore and so what
you're doing is I completely get but I
think a much more interesting thing to
do would be to take the money that would
presumably go into this
and create unbelievably Exquisite tests
for for doping in athletes so there
isn't a Level Playing Field for
everybody and then we go back to basics
and it becomes much more interesting
well the world anti-dubbing Authority
has effectively an unlimited budget
courtesy of taxpayers and the
international Olympic Committee uh and
so they do have the most Exquisite tasks
and the best machines and you know what
is they don't they're not good they
don't work the EPO is undetectable
um well ultimately
scientists uh are going to always outwit
the these tests so even if we doubled or
tripled the budgets of the world ended
open Authority I don't think would make
any difference right this this machine
has gotten larger and larger over time
and what is ultimately
quite unfortunate is that the athletes
of the World when they get accused of
doping first thing that happens is they
get dumped by their Sports federations
dumped by all their sponsors and they
have no Financial capability to fight
those charges and so it creates a very
unfair playing field and let's also talk
about what is the definition of a
performance enhancement
and so according to the world
anti-doping Authority their definition
of a performance enhancement is among
other things does it affect the spirit
of the sport it's purely a subjective
test and so you say you're not in hand
do you drink coffee no but tea tea it's
caffeine industrial quantities
right and that is a performance
enhancement if you go and run your 10K
in the park having uh 10 Cups of Tea
yeah you'll probably run it a lot
absolutely Viagra apparently makes you
wrong absolutely
[Laughter]
I agree I mean on a practical level
though how will your competition sit
alongside the Olympics because
presumably any athlete who now announces
that they're going to take part
everyone's going to look and then say
well they must have been doping in the
first place so in a sense anyone who
takes part in your competition is gonna
have to completely cut ties with the
normal world of Athletics
well the objective is to pay prize money
absolutely and to create a fair
compensation structure for athletes so
one of the things that I've learned
going through this process talking to
hundreds of Olympians is what abject
Financial poverty that they live in even
if they have a chest full of gold medals
and this is something that was quite
enlightening to me because I thought if
you win a gold medal you're financially
set up for life and that is not the case
and so we want to create a fair
compensation structure for our athletes
and the Olympics do not right eight
billion dollars in Revenue comes into
the Olympics uh Thomas Bach the ISD
president flies around the world and
private jets he lives in the palace paid
for by the ioc that the athletes of the
world aren't being paid anything and
it's really really unfortunate that
Excellence is not being rewarded and so
ultimately we're creating a fair
compensation structure including giving
stock to athletes so that they become
co-owners of this movement but surely if
you'll say Michael Phelps You've Won
several gold medals if he signs up
tomorrow everyone's going to look at his
achievements and say well he must have
been doping before that I mean do you
accept that well I was actually speaking
to one of the most decorated swimmers in
the history of swimming
um uh and he told me that he would love
to compete because he's retired right
he's retired with a chest full of gold
medals and he's now ready to wants to
jump back in the pool and says oh you
know taking performance enhancements
interesting if his time's on performance
enhancements were slower than his boots
what I'm interested in is on your
website you have a hall of Shame yeah
section where you show world records
that were set and then were canceled
because the athlete was found to be
taking drugs are you not slightly
worried that the public has no interest
in those records there is no clamor for
them to be reinstated people when they
look at
um I don't want to name any names of
people who have been caught doping I
can't remember them
it's not on your website I think you've
got Florence Griffis join us
is that I'm not sure she was ever done
but she ever caught doping uh I'd have
to research this you've got them
canceled the websites and you say this
is shameful they should stand they
should be celebrated yeah but the fact
is that the viewing public of Athletics
don't celebrate them already we have no
interest in them so why do you think we
will have interest in them when you in
your in your format oh absolutely
because we're trying to create two
separate classes of World Records to
recognize that there's a natural world
and there's an enhanced world and we
should recognize that there are some
world records that are objectively
natural world records and then there are
some that are enhanced world records and
so the you know Tour de France times
that Lance Armstrongs that are
definitely enhanced world records and
should be celebrated as the best of
humanity and science there's an honesty
to it which is undeniable but I think
you've already just used the word
natural and enhanced and
99.99 of the human population is natural
I don't think that's true at all
absolutely not absolutely not you know
we are
um Rife with
pharmacological enhancements not
generally performance enhancing well it
depends what you define performance
enhancing as the caffeine caffeine yes
caffeine yeah
fully available name another one uh
azembic which is the most popular uh
weight loss drug in the United States
now is arguably a performance
enhancement yes right
um you know we could go on and on about
um you know just walk into the GNC or a
Holland and Barrett according to you
know peer-reviewed scientific research
20 of the goods in those stores would
get you banned under the water code
right we're not talking about uh just
you know Black Market injectable
steroids here the the the breath the
definition of performance enhancements
by the world anti-doping Authority is
quite Broad and there's something called
a therapeutic use exemption so a lot of
athletes uh you know claim to have
asthma a lot a lot stairs remarkable
yeah it's remarkable how many athletes
have asthma
um and that allows them to take certain
drugs that uh wouldn't otherwise be uh
allowable and so many people have
actually argue to us that there should
be three categories there should be the
full natural and let's debate what full
natural actually means therapeutic use
exemption and then enhanced I mean isn't
that just the argument for the status
quo that I know you say that like
caffeine improves your times and so on
but we kind of you can kind of sort of
blur the lines about anything and you
can sort of say well we all kind of know
what cheating is when we see it we can
kind of just sense it and like the
example of swimsuits for example
suddenly all these athletes breaking
previous World Records when they're
wearing these swimsuits we all can kind
of smell the difference and kind of know
it I mean isn't that isn't that the case
do you think we should basically you're
saying that we should abandon the
imperfect for something in my piece I
say that uh if the testing was perfect
which it isn't and the testing is I
think we have to agree with rubbish it
could of course be perfect I think
science can find out what's inside
people's bodies uh if it was probably
fine however I would draw the limit
instead of saying I would go the
opposite way to you're saying all bets
are off take whatever you like I'm
saying you if anything is found in your
system that you couldn't get in a normal
Supermarket A well-stocked Supermarket
then you should be not allowed to
compete no but that argument doesn't
hold up because I can cross the street
from you know Sainsbury's and go into
Holland I'm saying in Sainsbury's you
can you can only take it sweep test yeah
what do you think of that you can't take
anything stronger than than what you can
find in a supermarket uh but that's an
Ideal World and an idea of course I
think yours is a vision of Hell mine's
an Ideal World
well the the current system doesn't work
right so the Olympics have gotten too
large too expensive they've literally
bankrupted countries
um and you know the core problem is they
move around every four years they build
a dozen stadiums and they throw them
away after two weeks it's so weird the
whole thing's corrupt yeah it stinks and
I want to create a better system for the
athletes
um and open up a whole new world of
possibility
and David we could probably talk about
this all day but we're going to leave it
there now thank you very much Isabel
Hardman is written in the magazine this
week about one of the latest diet fads
using glucose monitors to lose weight
it's been hailed as a success story from
a number of doctors is it right for
healthy human beings to try and control
their glucose levels Isbell joins me now
Isabel thank you for joining us on
spectator TV
um you're writing the magazine this week
about the latest health craze which is
people measuring their glucose levels uh
can you tell us a little bit about that
and and why people are doing this
yeah I don't know whether you've seen uh
these people at
but just in public with these yellow
patches on their arms they're becoming
more obvious now that it's summer and
people are wearing strappy tops and so
on uh they're yellow they're on the back
of your arm and they say Zoe on them um
and these are um continuous glucose
monitors that people wear as part of
um the Zoe program or other programs
have similar uh branded monitors
um and they are not for diabetics uh
they are for people who are just
interested in their blood glucose levels
in what foods make them Spike
particularly
um and the effects that this have this
has on how they feel as well
um Zoe's not a cheap program it's over
200 pounds
um and it's part of uh a program that
also looks at your gut microbiome and
you have to send samples of your poo
um to their lab and they analyze how you
respond to all kinds of different foods
and then help you come up with a
tailored eating plan basically
um to become healthier and on one level
who wouldn't want to know more about
their body about how it responds to
certain foods he wouldn't want to feel
better
um I mean some of the advice that the
Zoe program gives the things like you
know eat 35 different fruit and
vegetables a week because that's Optimum
for your gut microbiome some people
might be horrified by that because they
struggle to eat five in a day
um but it that's not actually
particularly
um something that you'd need to pay 200
pounds to do but I think that
the problem that I have with these broad
glucose monitors and the problems that
dietitians and nutritionists who I've
spoken to have got with them is that
they're not really relevant if you're
not diabetic in that your blood glucose
does naturally Spike after eating and
that's a sign that your body is
producing insulin um to deal with it the
problem that you have of your diabetic
is you have uh constantly or dangerously
elevated blood sugar levels and your
body can't process those
um so it vilifies what is really a
natural and healthy response in our
bodies and suggests that we need to
start worrying about that it also I
think most people go on a diet because
they want to lose weight I mean they'll
you know dress it up one way or the
other and they'll say you know I want to
be healthy I want to be fit I want to be
stronger but generally it's actually
they want fat loss and I think it really
over complicates fat loss and suggests
that you have to spend 200 pounds and
send packets of your poo somewhere
um to lose weight which you don't so so
just be clear so the people who run this
study
um Zoe and the similar ones they're
making very clear that they think it'll
be good for you if you can sort of work
out from your glucose levels what's
right for your body is that and you're
quite skeptical of that is that right
yeah I'm mean I I don't think there's
anything sort of particularly evil about
the Zoe program I you know lots of
people say that it has made them feel
healthy I just think that the idea that
your blood glucose spiking is a bad
thing is really unhelpful that's that's
the main problem is that it's part of
this wider movement and I talk in the
piece about the glucose goddess who's
written this book about how to hack your
body's response to um blood sugar in
particular doing things like drinking
drinking vinegar before your lunch
um which I mean
I just think no level of fat loss is is
worth that to be honest
um
what you know you've got to live your
life rather than being totally miserable
and vinegary but um but again she's
basically suggesting that we need to do
things
to engineer our bodies to not have this
healthy response to eating food and I
mean one of her suggestions was I think
covering
um a piece of fruit in peanut butter
um because it will change the way in
which your body will process fats and
sugars I mean yes but that's partly
because you've covered fruit in a whole
load of very fatty oily peanut butter so
I mean sort of no Sherlock the
sun's terrible to be honest um do you
think it does sort of encourage a bit of
hypochondria as well or I know a lot of
people
um and you've talked about the past a
lot of people uh sort of get fixated
with clean eating and that kind of thing
and do you think that's this is tying
into that I I think possibly I mean I
think there's always going to be uh
wealthy healthy worried people who are
prepared to spend money
um over complicating their lives
um when actually
I mean I I do think that one of the
reasons people are prepared to do this
is nutritional literacy in this country
is really really bad and we just don't
know what we should be eating I don't
think many people actually know how many
calories are in things they don't know
how many calories they should be having
every day or what sort of energy
expenditure that they have is and they
don't know what macronutrients are so I
think it sort of feeds on that confusion
that people have that they sort of want
to be healthy but they don't really know
how but my personal views you don't need
to spend that much money to learn about
a healthy diet you definitely don't need
to spend that much money
um to lose fat if that's what you want
to do you just need to go into a calorie
deficit basically and one that's not too
steep
um there's quite a few really
interesting uh people in this space like
um a guy called the fitness Chef um
who's on Instagram who debunks a lot of
this kind of good food bad food
um stuff and points out that you know
often we don't know the calorie content
of things so we say avocado toast is
good food
um and jam on toast is bad food when
actually the caloric content of the
latter is much lower and and you know
avocado is a good healthy fat and it's
got more macronutrients in it and so on
but actually you're consuming way more
calories if you have Avo toast which is
you know such a Instagram eat clean
um good food phenomenon
um
um we should mention as well you say in
your piece that this that Zoe isn't the
only one these glucose one is not the
only thing that's been pushed at the
moment and these sort of devices are
growing can you can you tell us a little
bit about those as well yeah there's
also a device called uh Lumen which
allows you to hack your metabolism
um it allows you to understand whether
you're in fat burn or carb burn through
your breath
um
and again I don't you know it's sort of
it's difficult because I don't begrudge
people who want to spend their money on
that and to a certain extent the reason
I know about these things is because I
get followed around the Internet by them
because I am to a certain extent one of
the sort of part of the target market
for this you know I've got an Apple
watch that on the face every time I
check the time also tells me how many
steps I've done
um and I am interested in I'm interested
in macronutrients because I'm a very sad
person
um because I do quite a lot of exercise
I do a lot of running I do a lot a lot
of lifting and so I'm you know
interested in my protein intake so the
you know the advertising algorithms
think oh but she'll also be interested
in spending 200 pounds on this gadget
um and you know
a lot of people I know do end up going
down that route but I I just think that
you don't need all this expensive kit
and I think one of the things I say in
the piece also is that
actually most of us are very lucky to
have boringly healthy bodies you know
diabetics who I talk to are like why are
people wearing these glucose monitors
you know for me it's a symbol of uh part
of my life that is very difficult and
stressful
um and to a certain extent those glucose
monitors have made it much less
stressful because previous ways of
monitoring your blood sugar
we're much more invasive and painful
um but why do you need to make your body
sort of abnormal or I guess special
maybe maybe that's the sort of instinct
as people sort of wanting their bodies
to be special when actually you know
there's that saying you're not a Celiac
you're not gluten intolerant you've just
eaten too much bread and I think perhaps
it would be better if we just accepted
that but most of us our bodies are quite
boring and they're not that special well
I'll accept that um brilliant thank you
very much Israel
that's it for this week once again thank
you to canacord genuity wealth
management for sponsoring the week in 60
minutes can Accord will provide you with
the expertise you need to help build
your wealth with confidence visit
candywealth.com for more information
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]